wenn wir uns die fdp heute anschauen
hans uli jörges warum warum so mini
geschrumpft das ist ja schon der trend
das passierte denen in
schleswig-holstein schon jetzt sieht man
die kaum noch auf dieser tafel da so
klein süchtige fdp hatte während der
korona debatten jahre wegen der korona
jahre ein thema jenseits dieses gen
themas wirtschaftspolitik das war
nämlich die freiheit also die der kampf
gegen die ständige einschränkung von
grundrechten das hat die fdp wieder
stark gemacht in der wahrnehmung
erkennen viele leute die eigentlich eher
links wähler anfeuernd sein sagt das ist
die einzige partei die dagegen
aufgestanden ist die wähl ich diesmal
das aber vorbei dass die in der
wahrnehmung der menschen ist die korona
geschichte vorbei weitestgehend und was
dann übrig bleibt wenn man nach berlin
guckt und nach düsseldorf guckt ist dass
die dort die falschen ministerien
besetzen die nach außen hin keine
wirkung haben der große schulstreit in
nrw es vorbei da gibt es keine
ideologischen auseinandersetzungen mehr
die die die
steuersenkungspolitik der fdp hat dann
ein ende wenn der fdp finanzminister
ständig neue schulden macht er
dementiert sich ständig selbst und damit
ist dieser teil der politik weg und wenn
man dann noch hinguckt was die sonst
noch haben in der in der bundesregierung
sind das unauffällige ämter während die
grünen die entscheidenden ämter besetzen
und die spd die peinlichen ja das ist
der unterschied zwischen den drei
partnern die die spd ist peinlich die
grünen sind stark genau auf den
richtigen ämtern und die fdp ist nichts
mehr wert ist nichts mehr wert sagt
hansjörg ist die spd peinlich auch das
nehmen wir mit ihr aus der runde und die
fdp nichts mehr wert weil sie die
falschen ministerien halb sagt hansjörg
wyss und weil sie sich oder ihre werte
auch verraten hat in dieser corona
krisen die fdp hat schon ganz ganz lange
jedes politische rückgrat aufgegeben und
das ist genau das zentrale problem
dieser partei auch jetzt jeder ich finds
interessant wie sie gerade beschrieben
haben das die fdp eigentlich eine corona
verordnungs kritische politiker hat er
sie doch mal trat joachim stamp hat sich
beim kölner karneval hingestellt als
vize ministerpräsident und hat in einem
moment als ein teelicht nicht so einen
schrecken erinnere weil ich gedacht das
kann nicht ernst gemeint sein fröhlich
gesungen impft doch einfach mit
er fragt sich jeder was also was in
solchen leuten vorgeht und sie wissen
dann eben halt ganz genau dass das was
man eigentlich als markenkern der partei
erwarten würde nicht das ist was
hinterher rauskommt und die sich
zuweilen freut sich christian lindner zu
gehen sondern muss erst mal sagen dass
das in nrw natürlich für ihn eine
katastrophe ist denn er ist ja
bekanntlich aus energie und hat da auch
lange in dem parlament gesetz auch gute
wahlergebnis ungefähr das heißt er ganz
offensichtlich hat lindner überhaupt
nicht gezogen jetzt noch mal was so
corona politik also da hat natürlich
herr jörges recht die haben immer damit
ihrem freiheits logen haben sie stimmen
bekommen nur ist ja das problem das muss
man jetzt mal sagen kroner ist
tatsächlich ein tödliches virus und
insofern kann ich dann auch herrn stammt
verstehen wenn er im amt als vize
ministerpräsident letztlich die leute
auffordert sich impfen zu lassen nein
das kann ich verstehen weil es überhaupt
einige duelle thematik ist und man nicht
pauschal dahin gehen kann oder
ausgleichen wo liegt eigentlich ganz
offensichtlich sind sie also ein ins
gegner ich weiß nicht ob das jetzt hier
stehen wird
irgendwie leute die politik kritisieren
sind alle selbst gekämpft werde drei mal
geimpft
wir sind der auffassung dass es
selbstverständlich wie alle anderen wir
als good governance gewerkschaft sind
der auffassung dass es
selbstverständlich eine frage ist die
individuell jede für sich zum arbeiten
und dass es nicht angehen kann dass
jetzt aber ein leben stammt
aufruf ist für sie schon sozusagen geht
schon über ziele nicht in einem
regierungsamt hinstelle soll auf einer
karnevalsfeier übrigen und eines der
integrativen lieder der kölner an sich
kennt und dichte auf emst allen
vermietern bis doch nicht dann gehörte
wieder dazu dann ist das einfach nur per
pedes matching aller erster güte das hat
nichts damit zu tun dass das leitbild
des grundgesetzes der bürger ist der
souverän seine eigene informierte
entscheidungen aber das ist sondern das
ist der versuch ein bisschen folge in
irgendeine richtung zu drängen das ist
genau das gegenteil von dem wofür eine
liberale partei teurer gegenteil der
hatte ihre gewerkschaft zitiert die sie
gegründet hat die jetzt viele branchen
dort auch verein will unter anderem
viele pflegekräfte sind dort auch
eingetreten wahrscheinlich eben auch die
pflegekräfte gerade ausgerechnet die
dann eben im kritisch sind das kurz zur
erklärung dazu der vorwurf die fdp hat
ihre glaubwürdigkeit verloren nicht ganz
es gibt ja einen kopf der herausragt
immer noch der die ganze corona politik
der eu beigetragen das ist wolfgang
kubicki der es glaubwürdig der ist aber
der hat aber keine dunkel der
stellvertretende bundesvorsitzende
partei und er ist aber leider nur
sofern er hat kein ministeramt aber er
hat das repräsentiert nicht der
parteivorsitzende nicht die anderen
minister sehr viel weniger er wollte mit
kopien derzeit nichts zu tun hat ja
immer wieder kämpfe ausgetragen
verbündete außerhalb der eigenen partei
im bundestag besucht er war von anfang
bis ende glaubwürdig andere sind
geschwankt mal so und mal so geredet
linden hat sich ganz lange nicht
festgelegt wird bis zum tag der
abstimmung
hier sehen kann ist dass diese ganze
analyse deswegen die stimmen kann weil
wo hat die fdp auch ganz stark verloren
in schleswig-holstein wer ist da der
kopf kubicki dass
hamburg das ist ein manager meines
früheren verlages das ist ein manager
ein kühler manager der gewinnt keiner
wahl ausgeschlossen aber er hat ihn
nicht da hat die fdp jetzt ihre werte
verraten hat die ihre glaubwürdigkeit da
eben meine was schon stimmt ist dass die
fdp so sagen beim corona thema so getan
hat als wäre sie afd leid nicht also
auch immer so freiheit freiheit gut
drauf
für die freiheit
die die zentrale argument gerade gesagt
dass die fdp von den freiheitsgedanken
vertreten hat in der korona zahlt das
wäre bitter in das war doch deren idee
also in einen dialekt eine konsequente
politik dafür manieren das noch mal was
sagen zum thema freiheit dass man da
jetzt plötzlich das neue thema in
unserer sendung zu sagen ich will
einfach ganze umgebung der wahl seine
freiheit live die freiheit der afg zu
habe lassen das wäre mir ganz unangenehm
von mir aus was mir wichtig ist das
würde ich auch gerne loswerden denn das
corona virus verschwindet nicht er
sondern es kommt im herbst wieder 2,7
millionen menschen über 60 sind nicht
geimpft die sind alle gefährdet das
heißt weil diese ganzen leute sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen werden wir im
herbst wieder ein lock down haben sein
soll ist ein schwarz noch natürlicher
die wahrheit und deswegen ist als
nächster halt da wird jede qualität in
den passagen und deswegen ist es auch
nicht so dass wenn ich sage ich will
mich nicht impfen lassen das nur eine
nur eine entscheidung für mich ist
sondern die leute die sich nicht impfen
lassen werden erzwingen dass der rest
der bevölkerung das sind über 60
millionen flamen was wir machen sollten
wir haben sagen also wir haben doch
inzwischen alle gelernt dass selbst die
geimpften die dreimalige impfung auf der
intensivstation liegen weil sie die die
infektion gekriegt habe da dass sie
andere anstecken dass wir sollten sie
diese gar nicht mehr
wissen wir doch wissenschaftlich aber
schätzen einen nur selbst
bestimmen laut
herrmann aber ich möchte noch die frage
mit geben einmal dann stimmt was karl
lauterbach sagt aus ihrer sicht die
haben ja schon zitiert in der sendung
hat mit ihren sparen darüber gesprochen
der jetzt in der rheinischen post sagt
die cdu ist damit run schuld weil sie
die impfpflicht mit verhindert hat dass
jetzt mehr leute wieder an corona
sterben werden ja das ist so was
natürlich weil es ist das was herr
jörges sagt stimmt wenn man drei mal
vier mal geimpft ist kann man sich auch
anstecken aber die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass man auf der intensiv- und die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man auf der
intensivstation landet ist viel geringer
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass man julia
wie kommen sie denn darauf
wenn man wenn man kann andere anstecken
aber die phase in der man ansteckend ist
viel geringer die virenlast es viel
geringer dh die einzige möglichkeit den
virus zu bekämpfen ist dass sich alle
impfen lassen vollkommene uns alte sie
liefert auf jeden fall wieder wieder und
immer immer wenn wir hoffen dass sie nie
wieder emotionen als wenn sie
wiederkommt möchte ich sie nicht noch
mal mit karl lauterbach erleben dann
soll bitte eine etwas kühlere nicht wenn
sie die wahren gefahren aber gerade die
ja nicht minister ich will dann will ich
gerne frauen haben sie als ärztin ist